kevin
they found an air hostess who is up for
carrying drugs this does happen
uh when i was in prison in ecuador they
arrested the captain of an airline my
name is peter tritton aka posh pete i am
a former drug trafficker namely cocaine
from beginning of 2003 till the end of
2005. i served just over 10 viewers
imprisonment in ecuador today we will be
watching clips from movies and tvs about
drug trafficking judge how realistic
they are
the one thing i i've seen repeated in
films and there's this scene of you know
loads of women naked so they supposedly
can't steal the drugs in a lab somewhere
with loads of chemicals and loads of
drugs it's just unrealistic in my
opinion the women in the scene are
wearing masks and gloves it's likely in
a lab that you would have that sort of
protective equipment on because i mean
i've i've been in makeshift labs when
we're doing our thing and the amount of
dust and fumes and everything that gets
up into the air and on the hands the
chemicals are really toxic let me show
you distribution
how many dealers 28 looking at triple
there they've got about 48 people in
this scene
let alone the dealers having that amount
of drugs in one place at one time with
that amount of people it's just such it
would be such high risk all the
different parts of the operation were
all in one place never each individual
mechanism or part would be separate to
the other so the people that had the
safe house they wouldn't know people
that were in the lab the people in the
lab wouldn't know the drivers so if any
one part got hit by the police they
couldn't link couldn't be linked to the
others i would give this a five just
because it's all just too much in one
place
before long we were seizing 60 kilos of
coke a day
that could happen i mean there was an
instance a few years ago in spain where
boxes of bananas were literally getting
delivered to shops and they were taking
out the top layer of bananas and the
rest was full of cocaine the flower
industry in south america particularly
colombia is huge so any cover good as we
call it but generally cartels don't send
large amounts like this unless they've
got customs either paid off or they know
they've got a guaranteed in for the
authorities to get big hits like this it
means something's probably gone wrong
somewhere along the line obviously
for the cartels
we thought we're making a huge
difference
if you look at the name on the boat
it's guayaquil that's the city that i
was imprisoned in equivalent that's the
main drug trafficking route out of
ecuador up to central america and then
on into america i was in prison with
several people who were
working on the boats they were captains
of boats
truth is we weren't even making a dent
in that tube i mean you know that they
they tended to fit the cocaine to the
shape of whatever it was packed in order
to maximize how the amount you can get
in there kilos are normally wrapped with
a rubber skin there's normally about six
or seven layers
they let us have 60 so they could bring
in 600.
whether that's true i don't know the
cartel's giving up drugs so they can
bring in more maybe they do i've been in
prison with people from this in their
lower cartel and i've never heard them
say that they did that
[Music]
the progression of the process of
the making of the cocaine here is is
very realistic that's the base product
from
when the leaves are crushed down and
soaked in kerosene they then go through
a few more stages they're put in into
trays to dry it basically i mean they
have missed out a couple of stages i
mean as they would they don't
tell everybody exactly how to make it
the scene is very is very realistic but
they've got the the sort of temporary
camp set up out in the jungle somewhere
processing the leaves i mean the volumes
of chemicals that they're using in south
america they have the chemicals highly
controlled now so it's very difficult
for them to buy the volumes that they
need for one kilo of cocaine with ethers
you need at least six or seven liters
per kilo so you imagine if they're
making you know three four hundred kilos
a day that that you're talking about
tank loads of chemicals
without you would be given access to a
laboratory like that if you've given
away its location of where it was
you'd be revealing the whole makeup just
for kilo when they're producing 300
kilos a day if you're talking to a guy
that's running a lab like this you're
going to be buying i would have saw a
minimum 50 or 100. the way that they're
dressed in in these scenes is typical
because these guys working in the labs
they're out in the middle of a jungle
you know you're not going to be showing
off to anybody in there the actual
workers very poorly paid you know it's
bad conditions it's dangerous you've got
the colombian military looking for you
all the time i mean you can see that guy
there's sort of dressed half in military
fatigue that's quite common and often
they'll be dressed in rubber boots like
wellington's just because of the
conditions underfoot yeah around eight
they've done their research
[Music]
i was imprisoned again with a guy from
the cineloa cartel a pilot he used to
fly assassins just like this he told me
stories about literally coming down
jungle
you know airstrips like this
in a cessna with a ton and a half two
tons of cocaine in the back another load
of powder take it back to the states
with a quick stop to refuel in panama
under the protection of my old friend
colonel noriega they were paying off
norway uh it's been proven that he was
involved in drug trafficking i mean you
imagine the amount of money involved in
in all this trafficking that's washing
around there's so much corruption they
will try and pay people like noriega
i had to get some help i called these
boys my snowbirds they were using
multiple planes so they would probably
limit the amount of times they used a
certain plane in a month or however
frequently in order to try and avoid
detection i mean certainly in america
they would have records you know flight
plans and stuff like that we did things
like that when we were using passengers
for example we wouldn't use them any
more than one or two times in a month
[Music]
i know people have done this into
britain using light aircraft coming from
holland pre-destined drops zone you just
drop in and you have people waiting in
that area to to collect or you have like
a private runway and if you unload it
quick enough you make sure that you
you've got the place secured there's no
police just a fire out of the plane as
quick as you can and get out of there it
is quite high risk i mean that's still
happening for sure particularly in in
central america and south america maybe
not into america these days because the
security is that good
seven
so this is making the capsules just in
order to swallow uh i've seen them made
like this so this is a
press to just compress the cocaine in
order to make the capsule in this
instance they're wrapping them in
condoms which is quite often how they're
made i would say a very high risk way of
trafficking coco and depending on the
person's stomach generally you're
talking about 800 grams to 1200 grams so
around a kilo that you'll that they'll
swallow
i never sent people this way hey i
didn't want somebody ending up dead on
my on my account and b it was it was
quite risky but highly risky they all
tell you that the capsules are 100 safe
there's no way they can split all sorts
of stuff to get you to swallow them
whereas in reality is you know you start
a high chance of them bursting when i
was in ecuador it was in the news a
couple of people have swallowed capsules
that had burst and they'd been found
dead drug trafficking can be portrayed
as being glamorous a lot but it is not
very glamorous at all it's pretty
gruesome traits
i mean these are typical questions
though they they would ask to see you
know for example have you bought your
own ticket because if you haven't if
somebody else has bought it for you then
why
that's that's a that's a big red flag so
she's just trying to catch her out here
and see how much it costs and if she
knows if she doesn't then obviously
there's something wrong promise which is
quite unlikely in colombia's you know
eight hundred dollars a lot of money us
no you know
the ways of proving it obviously the
law enforcement will stop the passengers
x-ray them or nowadays you use the
scanner as well
which is a much more detailed picture of
what's going on inside it's definitely a
lot harder to use this method these days
another thing they'll do is they'll put
you in a room if they really think
you've definitely got drugs in you until
you go to the toilet and uh there's a
collection
pan so anything that goes through there
gets collated
[Music]
but this is sort of thing that happens
well i got stopped
on the first job that we did uh i
brought the temp back myself uh which
contains five kilos of cocaine
impregnated in brother i was over the
luggage allowance so i had to give loads
of stuff away in the airport but kept
hold of this great big ten run tent got
stopped in amsterdam at schiphol airport
questioned and released
and let through carrying five kilos of
cocaine i'd give that seven away but how
much she was swallowing the kind of
questioning they they undertook i've
gone into schools and just spoken about
what happened to me and how i became
involved in it and how bad it was in
order to try and prevent them from
becoming involved themselves
tunnels have been documented
it's a known method that they've used in
the past they just want to get it out
and get it dispersed i mean that's the
most dangerous point when it's coming
into the country so they just want to
get it out of that area and somewhere
safe to the safe house as quick as
possible really
chapel guzman was the head of the
civilian lower cartel he's a real person
he's in prison in america somewhere for
life these guys do oversee things the
amount of trust in people that you need
to be shipping tons of cocaine around
the world that's one thing in films
there's not quite
true is the this idea of the
super criminal they're just on a phone
and a laptop and everything happens and
all these people working for them and
they never go near anything ever yeah
i'd give this seven out of ten seems
really risky eric she's a stewardess
they don't check her bangs kevin they've
found a weakness in a system they've
found an air hostess who is up for
carrying drugs this does happen uh when
i was in prison in ecuador they arrested
the captain of an airline on several
occasions there were people involved
with the airlines that have been
arrested this is back in the day
i've met old school drug traffickers
where it was literally put drugs in a
suitcase and get on a plane and traffic
them because the you know the border
controls were so relaxed back then but
these days in particular after 9 11 the
border controls and the security
uh around airlines is so high getting
drugs through passenger aircraft is very
difficult pure coke uh it melts away at
about a 180 590 degrees
cutting agents they melt away at uh
about a hundred they're looking to see
if the drugs have been cut or
adulterated at this stage this is a
hundred percent a realistic method of uh
testing coke cake we used to use a piece
of cast iron with a thermometer set into
it and you put the cocaine on top of it
on the iron put that on top of a cooker
and different chemicals in the cocaine
burn off at different temperatures and
as you hear in the film cocaine in its
purest form starts to burn or evaporate
about 180 i think it is i know a lot of
cocaine is getting adulterated these
days with things like boric acid limit
hole which i think is a pig warmer it's
a multitude of things that they use to
cut the drugs with these cutting agents
are all pretty toxic i suppose so i mean
i wouldn't say you're taking any drugs
is safe but the more it's cut the worse
it gets fairly realistic
i'd say seven or eight
[Music]
the quantities involved in this clip
that are huge how realistic that is i
don't know because i wasn't involved
with methamphetamine but uh to me the
amount of people are there and the scale
in america i doubt it very much normally
there's
nearly always a hiccup things get
delayed there's a problem someone's
[ __ ] up but there's just always nearly
always some sort of problem
that's just to identify uh which
containers have the drugs in so they're
using the uv stamp which is obviously
not visible to the naked eye but as soon
as you put a uv light on it they're
gonna know which containers can have the
drugs in putting uv stamps on containers
is one way of identifying where the
drugs are
normally in any drug trafficking serious
drug trafficking operation you're going
to have
front businesses to facilitate the
movement of the drugs or the inflow of
the drugs or the outflow or the
laundering of money as well companies
are
quite often vital to
drug trafficking networks for numerous
reasons uh i'd give that probably a five
just the amount of people involved in
the scale
[Music]
i don't know
hey you're gonna drive to san diego tell
me that this is quite a common method of
moving drugs around putting drugs into a
caletta or hiding place in the vehicle
which they all have manufactured or made
certain vehicles have particularly good
hiding places voids the spaces that can
be utilized as hiding spots
[Music]
i mean the british police have got these
there's a mirror on a handle so they're
looking underneath the car to see if
there's any new welding spots anything
obvious or anything that's out of place
that might show a hiding spot obviously
they've got a sniffer dog there
i mean if you're that far into the queue
i mean you can't really run away from it
then it can be because as soon as you
get out the vehicle they're going to
spot you apprehended this is the first
one she's done but i mean they would
probably be using people that they'd
already used before anyway that they
knew were trustworthy and solid when we
were sending people we you know the
reason i did that first one myself was
because i didn't want to send people to
do something that i had so i'd be i
would be able to
know what to
tell them to expect quite often i would
go i'd be in the background somewhere
just to make sure they're all right this
is quite realistic to give that probably
six because it's fairly realistic i
myself have become kind of a little bit
bored of watching films about drug
trafficking having lived it i mean i've
witnessed um
so many people getting killed in the
most horrific
means and ways that you can imagine all
because of uh you know
the money that's involved so i mean if
you do think it's glamorous then i don't
know what life you're living but it's
not the one i lived that's for sure so
thanks for watching the clips today if
you want to see more of the same click
to the link above